did we fight well uh as well as could be
expected
it was never our forty golden roses
indeed
your brother and his new queen thought
you would be defending casterly rock the
truth is casterly rock isn't worth much
anymore
well it is to me that my fond childhood
memories won't keep cersei on the throne
so you just let them take it for now
they won't be able to hold it
you're in greyjoy's navy burned their
ships we empty the ladders before we
left
eventually they'll be forced to abandon
their position and march all the way
across westeros
and you took your army your real army
and went to where they weren't as rob
stalked it to me it was bring wood
there are always lessons and failures
yes
you must be very wise by now
my father always said i was a slow
learner if he was so clever
why didn't he take high garden the
moment your gold mines ran
dry i suppose i'll be able to ask him
myself
soon enough no more learning from my
mistakes
eh how will you do it
with that sword that was joffrey's sword
wasn't it
not that he ever used it what did he
call it
widow's whale he really was a
wasn't he
i did unspeakable things to protect
my family or watch them being done
on my orders i never lost a night's
sleep over them
they were necessary and whatever i
imagined necessary for the safety of
house tyrell
i did but your sister
has done things
i was incapable of imagining that was my
prize mistake
a failure of imagination
she's a monster you do know that to you
i'm sure to others as well
but after we've won and there's no one
left supposes
when people are living peacefully in the
world she built
do you really think they'll ring their
hands over the way she built it
you love her you really do love her
you she'll be the end of you
possibly not much to be gained from
discussing it with you though is there
what better person to discuss it with
what better guarantee could you have
that the things you say will never leave
this room
but perhaps you're right if she's driven
you this far it's
gone beyond your control
yes it has
she's a disease i regret my role in
spreading it
you will too i think we're done here
how will it happen cersei had several
ideas
whipping you through the streets and
beheading you in front of the red keep
playing you alive and hanging you from
the walls of king's landing
i talked out of those
will there be pain no i made sure of
that
that's good
[Music]
i'd hate to die like your son clawing at
my neck
foam and bile spilling from my mouth
eyes blood red
skin purple must have been horrible for
you
as a king's guard was a father
it was horrible enough for me a shocking
scene
not at all what i intended
you see i'd never seen the poison work
before
tell sassy i wanted to know it was me
you